and you ready for this sperm can live in
the vaginal walls for like three days so
you could if you you know if you're a
lady who's out there you could get
pregnant by two different men drop in
two different names no have you ever
heard of it
that's insane you're holding on my Beast
Google it have you heard of that no
Google it so so you could have so what
is super fungadation twins super super
Foundation twins
Super Woman has intercourse with two
different men in a short period of time
while ovulating it's possible both men
and Pregnant her separately so two
different sperms I'm gonna tell you are
they are they and then what are they
that's my question are they fraternal
twins I think they're just good friends
right
[Laughter]